bobby earlier that george used to live
in that trailer back in l.a which the
silver one
yeah
and he [ __ ] two and a half women in
there two and a half yeah so what was
one of them a little person no no it
just wasn't wait two and a half in one
night no no just overall
12 years so uh
that that trailer has an interesting
story my ba dad bought a steam engine
you know how to make any story sound
boring youtube
just skip ahead five no because if you
say it's an interesting story it better
be interesting it is look at the trailer
i know but i want to see what comes out
of his mouth now the provenance of that
trailer i love that one my father is big
into steam engines he was president of
the steam automobile club of america
and so he just travels the nation
looking for steam engines that people
have so he found that one that like that
was the trailer for the steam engine but
the problem is he put that trailer on
top of another trailer and it was all
too heavy so the tires were gonna pop on
the way back to michigan
so we said just leave that trailer and
the front yard
so then
that was like a month or two before
bryce moved out
to be my assistant at maker
and we were like that's a perfect we're
gonna make bryce live in the front yard
and uh you know we'll establish the
pecking order of everything we're fine
just uh
every month keep uh keep beers in the
fridge
so then you should be a storyteller on
calm
i'm about to fall asleep i'm still
intrigued i'm intrigued there's a third
actor there's a third act
so then we went and did one uh one trip
for like new year's and bryce just
unloaded all of his stuff into my room
and i was so mad
i was like
bryce you [ __ ] if you're gonna
make my room dirty i'm moving to the
trailer
and you have to stay here and pay rent
oh i see
and
then i saw this flag this
no we're not flat i saw a little smirk
on bryce's face like he that was exactly
what he wanted
yeah uh so i lived in the trailer for
what like six months well i was a senior
producer at maker studios
it looks really cozy i mean i don't was
there a bed in there there's a bullet
hole through it there is a hole in it
um i don't think those are bullet holes
those are just rivets that fell out and
what for
got a nice little sunroof it's beautiful
i don't like it and what does it mean i
didn't have like electricity in it i got
electricity in it i did everything can i
buy it off of you so that that could be
jules's house yeah when she's in college
and doug said that
that was parked underneath the
grapefruit tree so like if you had girls
over you just hear giant
is there an interesting story about your
ellen john glasses
uh yeah you copped my style when you
went to bought gucci's in uh
in hawaii
i copped your style he said he did the
lenses first with color
then hawaii you're
no no i would go more mitch hedberg but
no inspired
you know you can call it what you want
oh it is very much it's got a head
burger yeah oh you guys want to know um
i had a very interesting dream last
night i want to know you guys take on it
but i don't know if this ever happens to
you but you ever like dream of somebody
else and you have a full-blown
relationship and love affair in your
dream and then like you're just reeling
the next three days like you genuinely
feel connected to this person you've
never met no
well i had
unfortunate for you